>>Chris Gethard: My name's Chris Gethard and
these are my friends
from the Chris Gethard show, which we'll explain
a little later.
[Chuckles]
We'll specifically explain this guy, making
his way up to the stage, a little bit later,
I just wanted to say [laughter] first of all
thank you for having us here today.
I also wanted to say thank you for having
us as part of the Authors at Google New York
program,
and apparently we're very popular at your
Ann Arbor office who is watching right now.
[Cheering]
Why?
What's?
>>female #1: I am just cheering for Michigan.
>>Chris Gethard: Oh, you went to Michigan,
so you're cheering the concept of Ann Arbor,
not the fact that they're--.
We're apparently streaming to their office
right now,
so whoever is responsible for all the enthusiasm
coming out of the Midwest,
thank you so much.
I'm quite surprised by it, and I have no idea
how it happens.
I think it's sort of ludicrous that I'm here.
I'm not note, I'm not a very impressive man,
or notable person.
It is my birthday today.
It is my birthday so that feels good.
[Cheering]
Thank you.
I turned thirty-two this morning, and if you
told me that, um, when I was a kid
that I would one day be talking to Google,
I'd be very surprised.
Because "a", Google did not exist then.
[laughter]
and also I am sort of a not that smart, semi-border
line white trash Irish Catholic guy from New
Jersey.
So,it feels like a victory to be here.
Just to explain, I'm a comedian,
I've been working at a place called the Upright
Citizens Brigade Theater here in New York
for twelve years, and I'm the author of a
book that came out this year,
and I'm also the host of a public access TV
show that gets, like it's a buzzed about thing
right?
It's sort of like a cult thing in the comedy
world.
My book is called "A Bad Idea I'm About to
Do".
And when I was thinking about things I could
do here,
I was thinking I could just come and sort
of like read stuff from the book or whatever,
but that didn't seem that fun to me.
I'd rather kind of merge the idea of the book,
the title, "A Bad Idea I'm About to Do" with
the vibe of the show we do, on public access
TV
It also streams on the Internet and we do
podcasts and all that good stuff.
But I wanted to maybe talk today about, the
premise of the book is about
it kind of I continuously throughout my entire
life have entered situations knowing
that it's not a smart way to behave and knowing
that I'm about to do something that is
definitely a bad idea, and then I opt to do
it anyway.
[laughter]
And that's become a sort of defining quality
in my life, and some of that's rooted
in clear cut mental and emotional issues,
but some of that is just because I enjoy it.
I think that bad ideas are some of the most
productive ones and I would
actually argue that everything I've done that
anyone has ever enjoyed,
someone told me it was a really bad idea first.
So I wanted to talk about that and to kind
of put my money where my mouth is
I wanted to invite some people from the Chris
Gethard show so
this is my friend Shannon O'Neal
>>Shannon O'Neill: Hello.
[Applause] Hi!
I want you all to know I let my sleep cycle
style my hair.
>>Chris: You did?
So that's bed head?
>>Shannon: This is bed head.
>>Chris: You have bed head.
>>Shannon: I woke up at eight A.M. and I didn't
do anything about it.
>>Chris: Okay, and also, and before we can
get into any of that, my friend Bethany Hall
is here.
Thank you for being here Bethany.
[applause]
>>Bethany: Hi.
>>Chris: And Bethany and Shannon, would you
agree with that while everyone at Google is
very nice,
this office and environment is somewhat terrifying
to people who don't come here every day?
>>Bethany: Absolutely.
>>Shannon: Feels like my brain was stolen
as soon as I walked in.
[Laughter]
>>Chris: Yeah.
Yeah.
Everyone, we were told six different times
today that everyone we'll meet
today is a Type A personality, and I was too
scared to say that I'm not sure what that
means.
[laughter]
>>Bethany: I keep feeling like I'm going to
do something wrong and we're secretly being
monitored,
so I'm like can I really take this water.
>>Chris: Yeah.
We're outwardly being monitored.
>>Shannon: See, there are cameras recording
this.
>>Chris: There's cameras outward monitoring
>>Bethany: Wee,
>>Chris: So, here's what's going to happen.
I'm going to give a talk about this idea
of bad ideas and why I think a lot of times
they actually are very productive,
to go through on bad ideas to follow your
gut instinct even when you know something's
probably not productive.
And to sort of is
somehow make today a bad idea.
What I've invited Shannon to do is Shannon
has a number of tools and implements that
are going to
be a physically not pleasant for me to experience.
She's got a small whiffle ball bat that we
often use on our show to hit
each other, and she's got a vuvuzela that
can be very loud and in can be in my ear at
any time.
>>Shannon: [blows air]
>>Chris: you've got to play that like a trumpet.
>>Shannon: [blows air] I don't know how to
do it
>>Chris: No no no.
Do you know how to do it?
Like this, [blows vuvuzela] Do you know how
to do that?
>> Shannon: Do I have put my hand like this?
>>Chris: We should have clearly practiced
first..
[Shannon honks vuvuzela weakly]
>>Chris: Oh God, this is already horrible,
horrible,
[laughter]
[Shannon blows vuvuzela]
>>Chris: Like that.
>>Shannon: I just have to put my lips in make
out form.
>>Chris: Yes, yes like a trumpet.
We've also got an, she's got a device it also
involved
that will electrocute me which we don't need
to demonstrate before it's done.
But this is a small low level Taser.
>> Shannon: You don't want me to demonstrate
it?
>>Chris: Not right now.
No no no no.
We'll get to it later please.
[Laughter]
>>Chris: So as you can see, what's going to
happen is I'm going to be giving my talk
and Shannon's going to be tormenting me the
entire time.
That's definitely a bad idea,
but in the style that I know and my way that
I think bad ideas are good ideas,
what I hope is that it will make things more
entertaining, and engaging, and watchable,
to know that it is not just some guy rambling
on for forty five minutes.
It will also involve torture, and physical
pain,
and all the other stuff that I think is funny.
>> Shannon: You have to look straight ahead.
You keep looking towards me.
>>Chris: I know.
I'm so nervous.
And Bethany has a conscience, that's why Bethany
was invited today.
Bethany is a very sweet, nice person and my
hope is she'll calm Shannon down things go
too far.
Although, what are both of your opinions on
that?
>>Shannon: It's not going to happen.
>>Bethany: It won't.
I'll try.
>>Chris: Okay, Try your hardest Bethany to
keep me safe when Shannon goes crazy.
And this odd gentlemen right here, is a character
from our show known only as the Human Fish.
Our understanding is that he's a half man
half fish creature who recently emerged from
the sea
[laughter]
I invited him primarily because it is hilarious
to me that I'm explaining this at Google Headquarters.
[laughter]
That's hilarious that I just got to say this.
So the human fish, he hasn't completely mastered
English yet,
But he does have these internal battles where
he figures out the world.
Likely any given time,
You can say "Human Fish, what on your mind?",
and he'll tell you what he's internally struggling
with right now.
So, he Human Fish what's on your mind?
>>Human Fish: Ann Arbor versus Anne Bancroft.
>>Chris: Ann Arbor versus Anne Bancroft, who
wins that battle?
>>Human Fish: Anne Bancroft.
>>Chris: Anne Bancroft?!?!
>>Shannon and Bethany in unison: Ohhhh!
>>Chris: I want to apologize to everybody
watching in Ann Arbor.
Personally, I disagree, but the Human Fish
is apparently a huge Anne Bancroft fan.
Then you can also ask him specific things,
like you could say,
"Human Fish, Google vs. Facebook.
Who wins?"
>>Human Fish: Google.
>> Chris: Google.
Thank God you said that!
[laughter]
Because it would've been very awkward if you
gone in the other direction.
So I do encourage everybody in here at any
given point feel free to interrupt us,
if you just want to know what's on the Human
Fish's mind, he'll tell you,
or if you have a specific question.
I don't know if anyone wants to yell anything
out
but please feel free to interrupt literally
at any given point.
It will be the most enjoyable portion of the
afternoon, I believe.
You can always ask, Human Fish, what's on
your mind now?
>>Human Fish: Trampolines versus Lady and
The Tramp.
[laughter]
>>Chris: Trampolines versus Lady and The Tramp.
This a tough one, those are both enjoyable
things.
who wins?
>>Human Fish: Lady and The Tramp.
>>Chris: Lady and the Tramp wins, okay.
>>Shannon and Bethany, together: We have a
question in the front row.
>>female #2: Do you have to like, is it a
versus thing, one versus the other?
>>Chris: Primarily yeah.
But thank you for getting the--
>>female #2: the rules of it.
>>Chris:Yeah, getting the rules of it right.
But you can--.
I mean we can phrase pretty much.
Did you have something
specific?
>>female #2: Well it was not a versus
>>Chris: Okay, that's fair.
>>Shannon: Let's try it though.
>>Bethany: What is it?
>>Chris: We can try it.
>> female #2: I just want to know what he
thought about sharks.
>>Chris: sharks okay.
So the way to do that would be to gauge it
versus other animals.
Like sharks versus dolphins who
wins?
>>Bethany: What if we just tell him sharks?
And see what happens.
>>Chris: We don't know what'll happen but
he probably has a lot of opinions on sharks
[laughter]
'cause they're his natural enemy.
He lives in the Hudson River.
We found out recently that he is a fresh water
being.
[laughter] He's a freshwater not a salt water
>>Shannon: Dirty fresh water being.
>>Chris: Sharks versus dolphins?
>>Human Fish: Dolphins.
>>Chris: Shark vs. an octa- A sharks versus
an octopus?
>>Human Fish: an octopus.
>>Chris: sharks versus a squid?
>>Human Fish: a squid.
>>Chris: sharks versus starfish?
>>Bethany: A shark versus anything?
>>Chris: anything a shark versus anything
else.
>>Human Fish: anything else.
>>Chris: He doesn't like sharks.
That's his feeling on sharks he doesn't like
them, but thank you very much for your
contributions to this very important talk.
Um [laughs]so dumb, right?
So dumb.
Okay, so like I wanted to talk about, let
me just explain a little bit about my book
because I feel like that is why I was asked
to be here, and I should just explain some
of the things
that I've done in my life that led to me writing
a book.
So, some of the stories, there's one where
a guy in college, when I was in college,
this guy from, I went to Rutgers University,
[electrical crackling] OW!
That was horrible,
that was really horrible.
So this guy, I went to Rutgers University,
the state school of New Jersey,
that's who I am, and this kid who went to
Princeton who I didn't know, managed to sort
of quasi-hack, hack into my computer,
and cut of my access to AOL's Instant Messenger
program, and my response was to drive
to Princeton, break into his dorm room, and
threaten to fight him.
In his dorm room, I broke into his house.
Said at one point, "I am in your house, and
there is nothing you can do about it."
And he started crying.
That's something I did in 1998.
I also, in 1998, signed up for one night to
be a manager in a pro wrestling league.
[laughter]
When I was in high school, I volunteered to
go on the Scared Straight Program.
I was the only volunteer.
It didn't go well, it wasn't pleasant.
I thought it would be funny, it wasn't funny
at all.
There's a story in there how when I was in
college, I signed up for a class on animal
husbandry
where I had to raise a goat for an entire
semester.
[laughter] At the end, I competed in a goat
show,
a competitive goat show.
[laughter] That also didn't go well.
There's a story in there about how I decided
one time,
instead of fixing my diet, what I would do
is get a colonic.
That one went about as you think it would
go.
[laughter]
There's other ones in there.
There’s, I signed, I once entered a jujitsu
tournament.
Me!
That's ludicrous.
You guys have known me for five minutes, that's
so stupid, right?
It was stupid, again, didn't end well.
The stories in the book, that's just a small
sampling.
A lot of things in there where all of those,
I knew
they were bad ideas.
I knew they weren't going to end well, and
they didn't end well, but they did lead
to this book.
And like I said, every, pretty much everything
that I'm proud of, is something
someone told me was a bad idea.
All the stories I have, and all the other
things that have
happened in my life, and I hope that by sort
of talking about that, "a" I can kind of make
sense
of it for myself and also maybe put out the
idea, into the world, that bad ideas, if your
gut tells you
to do them, do them.
And hopefully it will also help me validate
my own poor life decisions.
[Laughter]
So, for example, this book that I'm talking
about, that exists, that I'm very proud of,
that's been met with pretty much positive
reviews, there's been a couple bad reviews
and a couple, you know,
we're all Internet people here, you're never
gonna get all positive Internet commentary,
right?
I never do.
I once had someone say on the Internet, not
about my book, about a video I posted " you
should advertise your
need for parental love on that billboard of
a forehead."
That was once something that was typed about
me.
We did a show in North Carolina a few months
ago, and someone after the show went on Twitter
and at Chris Gethard said,
" Chris Gethard is heroically ugly, like Abraham
Lincoln.
He is so ugly it takes bravery for him to
continue living."
So that's the Internet.
So that's how the Internet responds to me.
[Laughter]
But by and large, people have liked the book.
They think it's funny, they think it's engaging.
A lot of people seem to identify with it.
I talk pretty openly about how I struggle
with depression,
For a lot, you know, probably not gonna try
and go fight an innocent Princeton kid unless
you've got some issues,
and people say they can identify with it.
And that's nice, but even that, the book,
when I first decided to do a book, I had a
manager because I was doing comedy for a long
time, and my manager came to be my
manager because he liked the web series that
I made and posted on YouTube, which you guys
are all familiar with,
because you own it, and that's crazy.
That's crazy.
When Kate, who organized this, said you have
to sign these things for
our YouTube channel, which we own, I was amazed
to realize you don't own your YouTube channel
that you post these on, you own
YouTube.
[laughter]
That's crazy.
That's really crazy.
I put videos up that get eight hundred hits
on YouTube.
You guys own it, that's nuts,
why am I up on the stage?
You should be filling me in on what I can
do.
Anyway, I had this manager and he liked this
web series that that we did and we sold it,
we sold it to this company,
and he gave them the rights, and then he said
we should keep doing that, that we could build
stuff on that.
He said we'll get agents out of that, and
I be able to talk to all the agents, and I
said I want talk to the agencies that
have a book department because I'd really
love to write a book.
I have this idea for a book.
He put it off, and and put it off, and then
eventually, I kept bringing it up.
I said "I don't know how long we wanna make
this web series for.
It's getting kind of old and kind of stale,
and I'd really love to talk to somebody who
can help me
write the book."
And he said, and I quote, "Chris, no one wants
to read your dumb stories."
And he explained to me
why was such a bad idea for me to not continue
this web series and instead focus on a book.
So I fired him in 2006, and now, six years
later, I have a book that people like, and
that's something that I like
to sort of talk about, and brag about.
Here's another thing.
Here are some of the things we've done together.
[Bethany laughs]
Human Fish, what on your mind right now, before
we continue?
>>Human Fish: Shelley Duvall versus Mr. Peanut.
[laughter]
>>Chris: What did they even have to do with
each other?
>>Human Fish: Shells.
[laughter]
>>Bethany: Oh!
>> Chris: Mr. Peanut has a shell, so Mr. Peanut
versus Shelley Duvall.
Who wins?
>> Human Fish: Shelley Duvall.
>> Chris: That's good, that's really good.
So something that we all accomplished together
with our show,
in a, right before Christmas in 2009, I decided
that what we needed to do to get our show
more attention
was book a celebrity on our show.
We were doing our show at the UCB Theater
at this time, which is really small, if you've
ever been there.
I decided why don't we aim big, why don't
we go for someone completely unattainable.
So I went on Twitter, and I asked Sean "Diddy"
Combs if he would appear on our show.
[laughter] Which is ludicrous.
A guy like me
should not be hanging out with "Diddy" Combs.
It doesn't make any sense, it's Puff Daddy,
he produced "Ready to Die."
He and I have literally nothing in common,
there is nothing that Diddy and I have to
talk about with each other.
I can't
imagine there's anything about my life
>>Bethany: Shannon! Shannon!
>>Chris: Oh God, Oh God, what is it?
Okay.
That wasn't hard, you held back on hitting
me there.
>>Shannon: Yeah.
>>Chris: Okay, because Bethany got in your
way.
>>Shannon: I stood up and she--
>>Chris: So like I said, what does Diddy have
to talk to me about?
Nothing, but I asked him,
and I kept asking him.
And for six days, I kept asking him and other
people on Twitter saw what I was doing
and thought it was funny, and, um, helped
us ask him.
And then, for some reason, on New Year's Eve,
the leading into 2010,
Diddy said "Who is Chris Get Hard?" because
that's what my name spells out phonetically,
that's the word Gethard is
phonetically that.
And all these people are like he's trying
to get you on his show and then minutes later
I got a phone
call that came up as unknown number and a
guy said, "Mr. Combs would like to speak to
you."
[laughter]
And then I picked up the phone and, um, Diddy
was on the other end and he was like "What's
up?" and I was like "Not much
"Diddy, what's up with you?"
And he was like, "so what's your show all
about?"
And I explained it to him,
and he was like "Yes,it sounds cool.
It sounds really positive.
I'd love to do it."
And then I was freaking out, and I
was like,"That's really amazing."
And then at one point, when I was hanging
up, I said, “Thank you so much.
People aren't
going to really believe this is happening.
I think this will be like a really positive,
cool thing for people to see.
I
think it's going to do a lot, thank you.
I can't believe you would do it."
And he paused and said, ”Ask and ye shall
receive" And then hung up on me.
He hung up on me.
And it was amazing, it was pretty incredible
to realize that a human
being feels like he's allowed to behave that
way and can pull it off.
That was really a pretty great moment, and
then eleven
months later or was it fourteen months later?
Fourteen months later he did our show.
It took him fourteen months to find a date
that worked.
>>Shannon: It was a year.
>>Chris: It was a year?
>>Shannon: It was January to January.
>>Bethany: It was January.
>>Chris: Oh yeah, it was January 14th, 2011.
It took him a year to find a day he had open,
that's how busy he was,
and it was a pretty fun night.
It was a pretty fun night.
Again, not the smartest idea, not a great
idea but an idea that
paid off pretty well.
Oh what's going to happen behind me right
now?
I don't know, I don't know.
Another thing I wanted to talk about on this
topic of bad ideas was that a lot of times
the things that people have told me, that
things people have told me are good ideas
wind up not being worth anything at all.
And what I have found continuously is that
when I follow my gut instincts t they lead
me to good places like hanging out with Diddy
for one night.
And begging him on
stage to invite me to the White Party, which
he refused to do on stage in front of hundreds
of people.
[laughter] That's a bad idea
that turned into something I'm very proud
of, that we accomplished.
But I also wanted to talk about the fact that
I've had
people tell me certain things are good ideas,
that didn't turn out to be enjoyable experiences.
Like for an example,
I was briefly the star of a sitcom on Comedy
Central, and it was supposed to be my
[Shannon blows vuvuzela]
>>Chris: Oh God
>>Shannon: Bethany, I will wrestle you down!
[blows vuvuzela at Bethany]
>>Chris:Oh Bethany, you're asking for it.
You can let her do it, just when it gets too
far, you don't have to stop it.
>>Bethany: Okay.
>>Chris: That was never the point.
Let it happen, Bethany.
You'll know in your heart when
>>Bethany: You're trying to talk to these
people
[Human Fish blows toy]
>>Chris: Human Fish, why did you blow that?
What's on your mind right now?
>>Human Fish: Walt Whitman versus Walt Disney.
[Laughter]
>>Chris: Walt Whitman, the poet, the bard,
versus Walt Disney, the animator and also
Nazi sympathizer, who wins?
>>Human Fish: Walt Whitman.
>>Chris: Walt Whitman, that's good.
That's good.
You understand that Walt Disney had a dark
side.
Good, you figured that
out about the world.
So, I did this show on Comedy Central, and
everybody said it was going to be my big break.
It was
produced by Will Ferrell, and that was cool.
And then, uh, it didn't turn out well, to
say the least, it didn't go anywhere,
and it was kind of a public flop, and that
was hard, and everybody, it was very funny
to see how everyone behaves when
they're about to make some money off of you,
in a sense that I would get, for example,
knocks on my dressing room door and I
would open the door, and this happened three
different times that I would open the door,
and the guy would be like " Chris, man,
how's it going?"
and I'd be like "Pretty good."
And he'd be like "What's new?
Is there anything you need me to take care
of?"
And I'd be like, " I don't
really know what you mean by that because
I've literally never met you in my entire
life.
I have no idea who you are or why
you're behaving this way."
And he'd be like, “I’m one of your agents."
I was like "Really?"
And he was like, "Yeah, I work at
your agency.
I'm one of your agents."
Then I'd be like, "Then how come you've never
ever called me on the phone even one
time, and I've, this is the first time I'm
hearing your name?"
And they were all so nice when they thought
they were gonna
make money, and then the show failed and not
one of those three guys has ever spoken to
me ever again.
And the reason I
bring that up.
[Electrical crackle]
AHHHHH!
That was really loud and also physically painful.
[Laughter]
Okay.
>>Shannon: You have to fight pain with pain.
>>Chris: So my emotional pain that I was bringing
up you wanted to dissuade it with physical
pain.
Thank you, Shannon
for doing that.
I'm really glad to hear you laughing and having
fun right behind me.
Oh God.
>>Bethany: I'm having a great time.
>>Chris: You are?
You're enjoying that?
Good.
So after I did that show, every one told me
that the good idea I could do
was to move to Los Angeles, and go and try
to get more sitcom work.
And that sounded like something that was probably
smart, and probably like something I could
do, I'd just been a lead on a sitcom.
In my heart, what I realized was that the
experience of being a sitcom wasn't pleasant
and I shouldn't do it, and even though there's
more work for comedians in L.A.,
it wasn't really interesting work to me and
I'd rather stay here and be poor, and work
with these guys and let them hit me
on stage.
And sit shirtless on stage while they debate
Mr. Peanut versus Shelley Duvall.
And that lead us to the Chris
Gethard show, which I think is the worst idea
I've ever had.
The worst idea I've ever had.
Would you agree with that
Bethany?
>>Bethany: If it's the worst idea?
>>Chris: There are many aspects of it that
are by far worst idea
>>Bethany: Yea, um, I, I, I think it didn't
make a whole lot of sense when we started.
>>Chris: Yeah, especially when we did it on
public access.
>>Bethany: Yeah.
>>Chris: It was horrible.
>>Bethany: It was really terrible.
>>Chris: It was really terrible, and horrible
and an unwatchable show.
And I have to think, I don't know exactly
how to
research this, but I have to think that I'm
the first person in the history of television
to go from starring in a sitcom
to hosting a public access TV show,
[Laughter]
within one year's time.
That's a really bad sign of your career trajectory,
right?
To go from starring in a sitcom produced
by Will Ferrell, to hosting a show on a dying,
antiquated form of media?
That's probably not a good sign.
But I felt like it
was worth doing and we do a lot of fun stuff
with the show.
Just last week we had eight different people
make cardboard
robot suits, and fist fight each other on
the air.
And we've had a kick boxer come on and beat
me up.
We had a show called
"ruin this show" where we said literally anyone
who wants to can show up and do what they
can to ruin the show, while the
show was on.
It's a live show, we don't edit it.
They can come on our live broadcast and ruin
the show, and, man, did
they.
If it was not watchable.
We thought that would be a really fun charming
thing, it was not at all.
[laughter]
It was really horrible.
And we had gotten a huge break, I had appeared
on the Jimmy Fallon show the night before
and promoted it and said, "Everybody watch
this show, ruin the show."
And was it, it was really heartbreaking to
see, on our
live stream, the numbers shot up real big
because of Fallon, and as the show was progressively
more ruined, you could just
watch viewers leaving.
Just you could see the numbers getting down
to, by the end, there was about one-tenth
of the people
watching as were watching at the beginning.
And that was heartbreaking, but I was glad
we went for it.
We did a show
recently where a man, there's a guy in Sweden
who watches our show.
He's a real good guy named Skellen.
And it's pretty cool
to get calls on a public access show in Manhattan
from Sweden, and Australia, and Wales, and
also from so many
depressed teenagers.
[laughter]
It's pretty, it is fun.
It is fun to just get a call from a guy who's
like "Hi, it's me from Kentucky."
And I'm like "What
do you want to talk about tonight?"
And he's like "I'm just sorta sad and watching
your show."
And I'm like, "Cool, I'm glad you
felt like you could reach out."
But this guy named Skellen sent us a tin of
fermented herring, and he claimed, he said
this, this substance is the most
putrid smelling substance on planet earth,
and I don't think you guys have the guts to
open it in your studio.
And I said
frankly, there's no way I'm going to let a
Swedish man challenge American grit and know
how, not that I have anything
against Sweden, but I would like to think
that America has a reputation at least for
being tougher than Sweden right?
George Bush was our President a few years
ago,
[Bethany laughs]
so what happened was we opened the can, and
he was right and I was wrong.
It was really bad.
It was really, truly horrible.
There's no way, it smelled largely as if you
stuffed a bunch of cigarette butts inside
a dead cat's carcass, is what
I would describe the smell as.
Human Fish, you didn't like that smell, right?
It wasn't good and I saw a member of our
studio audience honestly crawl out of the
studio [laughter] and I was told at least
one person vomited outside.
[loud laughter]
>>Shannon: Can I ask Human Fish a question?
>>Chris: You can ask Human Fish a question.
>>Shannon: Sharks verses, what is it, fermented?
>>Chris: Oh, verses Surströmming?
>>Human Fish: Sharks.
>>Shannon: Oh.
[Bethany laughs loudly]
>>Chris: You like sharks better than Surströmming?
I wonder if you knew, Human Fish, sharks versus
regular herring?
>>Human Fish: Regular herring.
>>Chris: So it's only when you ferment herring
that you don't like them.
Okay, fair, thank you, Human Fish, for your
contribution.
So again, I feel like, opening that can of
fish, was a really horrible idea, and led
to a bad stretch of our
life, but hopefully it led to watchable comedy,
and fun television.
And, um, the other thing that I've realized,
that I wonder, I would even love to pick your
guys' brains about this
afterwards, is everyone keeps telling us that,
um, no one's going to put our show on TV,
on like real TV, and the sort of
area where they've kind of got us on that
is that the TV networks have all the decision
making ability, and all the money,
but where we've got them is we legitimately
don't care [laughter] 'cause we're doing something
really fun, and really
interesting.
And one of the things that I think I would
love to know from your guys' perspective is,
are you guys, and some of the big Internet
companies, planning on murdering network TV?
[laughter]
Because it seems like something that could
happen, seems like TV and the Internet could
just happen there, and as someone
in the entertainment business who's sort of
struggled to do his own thing, and have any
sense of integrity, I would love it
if you did.
[laughter] I would just LOVE if all of you
guys got together, you and the other big one
or two companies, and just
murdered it.
Just killed it.
Just say, why doesn't, why don't we just make
the technology so the sound and the picture,
which you're getting there, is good enough
that people can just download what they want
to watch and maybe pay a tiny sum for
it, and not be barraged with advertisers,
and then have it dictated to them by companies.
This is being recorded, and these
companies could potentially see me say this,
companies that don't know what they're talking
about, and make really
, uncreative, uninspiring decisions all the
time.
Which is a hard truth.
But I would beg you, Google, if there's anything
that gets across [laughter] please, I hope
your YouTube one hundred channels initiative
turns into the new cable, and just
crushes them, and gives people like us, and
a lot of the other creative people in New
York in particular, who don't want to
go to L.A. because that's where you have to
go to make it happen, a chance to make even
a somewhat decent living via the
creative output we want
[Shannon blows vuvuzela loudly]
>>Chris: Oh God, you're the worst human being
I know!
You are literally the worst human being I
know, but I asked you to do
that, so that's okay.
[Shannon laughs]
>>Shannon: I am your puppet. [she laughs]
>>Chris: You are, um, that's not true.
That's not true.
>>Shannon: I know.
>>Chris: But I would ask you very legitimately
if that's in the cards, because it will keep
people like me going in creating
our own content, on our terms, in the way
that we want.
>>male #1: If we do, it will have advertising.
>>Chris: It will have advertising.
[laughter] Thank you for being honest about
it.
But it'll at least be, like,
you can click "skip this ad."
It at least it comes up on the bottom, right?
At least you don't have to, right?
At least you
guys are doing it in a way that no one’s
going to eventually create a device so you
can fast forward through it, right?
At least you're doing it in a way that is
somewhat kind to the consumer, I would like
to think.
But it's really, I think, so
exciting to see things like podcasting take
over in the comedy world.
There's so many podcasts where people are
managing to
make their living doing stuff that they really
believe in, and it's because of people like
you creating devices that make
that palatable, and make that doable and the
technology to create those things at a quality
level if you want to put in
harder work than you would have to if it was
on a radio station or a television network
someday, hopefully, is really
inspiring.
So thank you guys for doing it, legitimately.
I feel like you guys probably hear a lot of
jokes about being a
scary corporation, and we had those at the
beginning, but also things like YouTube and
things like tablet devices give
people like us hope that we should keep going.
And I want to say, as far as being in Google,
Google New York, and sorry Ann
Arbor that I'm about to say the good things
about New York.
I don't really know how it works being here
versus being in your
California offices, but being an entertainer
in New York means that you're constantly told,
"You're not gonna make it.
You're not going to make your living off of
this."
There's less people who want to read your
writing, there's less auditions
to go on.
But what I would say is that New York is still
a place where you're challenged the most,
where there's so many
people we've met through our show.
One of the things that I think we all love
about our show is that it started out with
a
bunch of comedians, but the other people we've
met are film makers, and musicians who do
the weirdest stuff, and there's no
place for them.
There's bands on our show who are so creative
and so cool, and you can dance to their music,
and they wear
masks, and like there's one band, Bad Credit
No Credit, who's so awesome but they have
a trombone and a saxophone as their
main two instruments, and they're never gonna
get a record contract because no one is going
to make money off a trombone and
a saxophone.
But, man, would it be nice if they could.
And, man, is it nice that New York is just
sort of full and brimming
and teeming of people like that.
And I'm glad that our show has become a place
where they can come and hang out and do their
thing and I'm glad that our show is a place
where we've manage to promote it in some cool
places that made people actually
see them.
So, I'm sort of rambling and up on a soapbox,
and not saying anything revolutionary to you
guys, but I hopefully
wanted to explain some of the stuff that I
do, some of the stuff that we do, some of
the stuff that led to the book that got
me here and to being in existence.
And to some of the stuff that we do on the
Internet, and maybe let you guys know a little
about the perspective of someone who's creating
and really struggling and really opting in
to struggle because he believes
in doing it in his own way, and on the Internet.
And, uh, I do, I live in a two bedroom apartment
in Queens, and I don't
have a closet in my room.
Like that's how I have to live as a thirty
two year old man if I want to do this.
And there is the
temptation to just go out there and just try
to make money, but it's not an inspiring thought
to go out there and act on
another show that no one's going to like.
And then even, you see, like, I worked ten
years to get that show, our friends, we
have two, we have a couple friends all of
us who just work ten, fifteen years to get
a show on NBC, and they worked so hard,
and the show was so good, and it was so funny,
and heartfelt and smart, and it was great,
and that's not just because they're
friends of mine, and then it got put up against
Survivor and they pulled it after four episodes,
and there's just really no point
in working that system.
There's no point to working that system, and
to me, all the people who ever really inspired
me
are people who gamed the system, who twisted
it around like Howard Stern took radio and
did something totally different
with it and was constantly told "What you're
doing is wrong, and it needs to stop," he
just did it anyways.
David Letterman,
in his early days, just did stuff that was
really so weird, and he kept doing it.
And Andy Kauffman, and Jackass, and then
things that aren't even in the world of comedy,
like punk rock.
Eventually it got to a point where people
didn't need to get
real record contracts, they made their livings.
It's an inspiring thing.
And then even in the world of the Internet,
I'm just sort of a sup, I'm a nerdy guy who
just wants to read and consume information
and I read about things like the
phone freaks back in the day and how that
was a bunch of blind kids playing with the
phones, and then they started doing stuff
cool enough that other people started to notice,
and then those people started making computers,
and now, here we
are, at an office that, literally, reminds
me of the Death Star.
[laughter]
>>Shannon: We have a question in the front
row.
>>Chris: Oh yes!
Please
>>female #3:Human Fish, Punk rock
>>Chris: Punk rock
>>female #3: or pet rock
>>Chris: Or pet rock?
That's a great question, Human Fish.
>>Human Fish: Pet rock.
>>Chris: Pet rock beats punk rock?!?
An outdated gimmicky toy from the, you really
believe, NO this is a punk rock
thing
>>Human Fish: Pet rock.
>>Chris: I think you have mixed up what a
pet rock and punk rock are
>>Human Fish: Pet rock.
>>Chris: Oh, he is a pet, is that
>>Shannon: I think he's thinking rock, yeah,
rock and roll for pets.
>>Chris: Oh, rock and roll for pets?
>>Human Fish: Pet rock!
>>Shannon: So he's into rock and roll for
pets.
>> Chris: You're into rock and roll for pets.
>>Shannon: He probably doesn't understand
the concept of a rock that is a pet.
>>Chris: Okay, so let's put it this way.
Short, maybe three minute songs traditionally
filled with maybe an angry vibe done
on independent music labels versus a stone
that you pay eight dollars for and claim it's
a toy.
>>Human Fish: Pet Rock!!
[laughter]
>>Chris: Okay, how can we rephrase this?
The Ramones and The Clash versus something
you would find in your garden.
>>Human Fish: Pet Rock!!
>>Chris: Okay, okay, Human Fish, I think we
just have to move on.
I think we just have to move on.
So, I just wanted to put
that stuff out there, say thank you for having
me and hopefully my book is funny and hopefully
my show is funny but also
to sorta be
Oh my God, what is that?
Which one is that?
What are you doing?
[Bethany squeals]
If you're going to do it, just get it over
with.
If you're going to do it just get it over
with
>>Shannon: Lower
>>Chris: It's not working
[smacking sound]
>>Chris: Ahh, that was my
>>Human Fish: Pet rock!!
[laughter]
>>Chris:Ah ha ha, you aimed for the kidneys
>>Shannon: Yep.
I wanna make sure they're working.
>>Chris: What is that?
>>Shannon: You're thirty-two, you gotta check
your kidneys.
>>Chris: You're not doing me a service by
any means.
Bethany, you did nothing to stop her, you
have to find the middle
ground where you're too protective and not
protective at all.
>>Bethany:Well, now I'm just sitting here,
like, cringing, and trying to let it happen.
>>Chris:Cringing at what?
The violence or the quality of this presentation?
[laughter]
>>Bethany: Mostly, mostly allowing violence
to happen and trying to act comfortable about
it.
>>Chris: Yeah, that's fair.
I would say that's a fair gauge of where we're
all at.
Right, Human Fish?
>>Human Fish: Pet Rock!!
>>Chris: [laughs] So, I've been rambling long
enough, it just felt important to me on some
sort of level to come here and
say this is the perspective of a creative
person who writes, and acts, and specifically
to sort of say, this is the
perspective of someone who's trying to make
it happen on the Internet.
Almost all the promotion that my book company
wanted
me to do was via the Internet.
So much of what is asked of creators right
now, you guys would be amazed at how much
people,
like managers and agents in the entertainment
world, are like "So, we want to get this thing
out so, uh, just make a YouTube
video and it'll go viral."
And that's just what they tell you, "go make
a viral video, that's how we'll get your project
off
the ground."
That's what people think of it, they don't
know exactly how it's going to work.
They don't understand that it's
a hard process, that you have to put a lot
of work and effort into it, and have a game
plan and a strategy.
You would be amazed how many times people
are, I don't have that many Twitter followers
relatively, but how many times
people go, "Hey, so, this guy wants you to,
like, tweet this thing for him.
Will you do that?"
It's like, wow, people just really
don't know, so we're trying to make a TV show,
and we've basically found out that the Public
Access Network of New York
will give us a three camera studio, and the
only thing we have to do for it is fill out
paperwork and deal with all the
lunatic maniacs who have public access shows.
Like the guy who follows our show some weeks,
who his entire show, no joke, is
just him grinning while putting dollar bills
into ladies' thongs.
[laughter]
That's his whole show.
That’s his entire television show.
There's another one where a guy sets up a
camera on the passenger seat
of his car, and just drives around without
speaking, and they let him do that television
show.
That's a television show that
he does.
That's the network that we're on!
That's the network that we're on.
[laughter]
But we also put it out over a streaming service,
and we also archive the whole thing and allow
it for download as a podcast.
And, uh, hopefully, the technology will continue
to develop where, um, video podcasts are something
that can get people's
attention.
And our hope is that our hour long show is
something that, as technology changes where
the attention span of the
Internet becomes more and more of a TV level
and less of a watch two minutes and fifteen
seconds of this guy getting, you
know, kicked in the genitals by an adorable
squirrel or whatever.[laughter] Whatever the
videos are right now.
So hopefully,
someday the technology is there, so that's
where we're at, and that's who we are, and
that's why we dress up in these
outfits, and that's why we hit each other
with stuff because we want to be creative
as much as possible so that's in the
book, and that's on the show.
And I hope you guys will check it out, and
I thank you for listening to us ramble, and
I was
told that we should take some time at the
end in case there's any thoughts, or questions,
and like I said, I'd love to pick
your guys' brains about that, and if there's
anybody who works in those areas, or is just
interested in knowing like
what idiot comedians think the Internet is
good for.
We're happy to be here and we're happy to
answer anything, and we're
also happy to throw as many questions as you
want at the Human Fish, cause he always has
an answer.
>>Shannon: I have a question.
>>Chris: Sure.
>>Shannon: Why is there dog hair all over
this stage?
>>Chris: Why is there dog hair?
>>Bethany: Yeah.
>>Shannon: Do you see it?
There's like a pile of dog hair.
Is there a dog that roams the Google offices?
>>Chris: Was there some kind of dog show?
Was there some kind of recent dog show?
>>Shannon: Or a cat, was a cat murdered on
stage?
>>Chris: Cat murdered?
>>Shannon: Did Deepak Chopra murder a cat?
>>Chris: Deepak Chopra?
It was Tina Fey's presentation, How to Groom
Your Dog.
Hers had to be better than this right?
>>Shannon: Well, I watched it, it was immensely
better.
>>Chris: It was immensely better.
>>Shannon: Yeah.
>>Chris: This was just me like nervously rambling.
>>Shannon: This is great though.
Only one person left, that I saw.
>>Chris: Yeah, but there's like four dudes
who never shut their laptops, but that's okay.
[laughter]
>>Shannon: That's only four dudes though.
>>male #2: I shut mine occasionally.
>>Chris: You did shut
>>male #2: I have a question actually.
>>Chris: Oh great.
Yes.
>> male #2:It's a really weird one and it's
really specific.
>>Chris: Okay.
>>male #2: So, I'm going to try to keep it
as simple as possible.
Is there a section in the book
that talks about like a woodshed where some
unpleasant activities happened?
[laughter]
>>Shannon: Were you molested?
>>male #2: I searched for every variation
on the word woodshed that I could and I couldn't
find it so I think
I merged memories from another book with your
book.
It sounds like there isn't, or I should say,
it looks like there isn't.
>>Shannon: I think he's confusing your book
with the lonely, uh, The Lovely Bones.
>>Chris: The Lovely Bones by Alice Sebold?
>>Shannon: I think you read The Lovely Bones
by Alice Sebold.
>>Chris: Which I believe is a fictional novel,
whereas my book is a series of non-fictional
short stories.
No, I don't think
there's anything with a woodshed.
So did you read, you read the book?
>>male #2: I read the book, yeah.
>>Chris: And you were like, man I want to
read that woodshed thing again.
[laughter]
>>male #2: My band mate used the phrase, time
to hit the woodshed, in an email that also
mentioned your book,
which I had told him about.
>>Chris: Okay.
>>male #2:And I was like, Whoa he must have
read it because he's like totally referencing
that woodshed
moment.
[laughter] and I asked him later and he was
like, no, that's just a saying that people
say, and I just said it
>>Chris: And you still didn't trust him, you
still didn't believe him?
>>male #2: I didn't believe him.
I was looking for shed, shack, like you know,
like shanty, you know every
single word.
>>Shannon: You should
>>Chris: To my knowledge, there's no stories
about sheds, shacks, or shanties in my book.
>>Shannon: You should check your friend's
woodshed
>>Chris: Yeah, it sounds like he has some
deep secrets and you have some blocked memories
regarding a woodshed that are
very important to you.
[laughter]
>>male #2: He said it wasn't in the book,
so what's going on there?
>>Chris: I can tell you my best story about
a shanty, that's not in the book, if that
would make you feel better.
>>male #2: It would make me feel amazing.
>>Chris: So I worked for many years at a magazine
called Weird New Jersey, which is all about
haunted places and odd things
in the state of New Jersey, which was definitely
the best job I'll ever have.
[laughter] Riding around New Jersey looking
for ghosts.
And we got a letter, we got a letter once
that was like, you gotta to this place, Buttonwood,
which is in the
swamps of this one town.
There's this river, and down by the swamp,
there's all these shacks.
And back in those woods,
there's all these cars buried vertically in
a circle and no one knows who's doing it or
why.
So we were like, we gotta get a
picture, we'll call it 'Carhenge', and it'll
be great.
And we drove back there and we had to drive
past these shacks and
now, most of them had been abandoned because
of flooding from a hurricane that had come
through a year or two prior, but
there was one where there was all this like
stuff, like old washing machines, and car
engines just spread all over the lawn.
And we were driving and it was me and my boss,
and we got down by the river, and realized,
like it was kind of a confusing
area, and I was turning around my car, and
this pickup truck rolled in front of us, and
I was just like well, this can't be
good at all.
And it wasn't, [laughter] it wasn't good.
The guy, uh, we went to drive around him,
and his truck blocked the
whole, it was a dirt road we were on, and
then he put his hand out the window and just
went like that at me.
And his hand,
no joke, it looked like a catcher's mitt,
it looked like a catcher's mitt with a bunch
of Italian sausages on it.
And then I
saw the guy, and he was huge.
He had on this t-shirt that was like tearing,
and he was the biggest man I've ever seen,
and
then um, the crazy, the scary thing about
him was all his hair was white, except he
had a lump on his head and all the hair
growing out of the lump was jet black.
Like this weird lump with all jet black hair
growing out of it.
It was really odd,
and I was like "What's up, sir?"
And his response, honestly, his response was
[gibberish].
And I was like, well, what do I
do, how do you, how do I even handle this?
And he started yelling at me, and as I calmed
him down, I could understand him
better.
He was going "you come back here, you're stealing
things, we know there's this redhead kid coming
back here stealing
things".
And I was like, "I'm not stealing anything,
man, we're lost.
We're like looking for Carhenge, man.
Like chill out."
And he was like, "No, you're coming back here
and stealing things, and we're gonna teach
you a lesson."
And then he went,
"Do you know what the Second Amendment is?"
and I was like, "Yeah, I'm aware of it."
And he goes, "It says that I'm allowed
to shoot you."
And I was like, “That’s not what the Second
Amendment, [laughter] that's not what the
Second Amendment is."
And he's like "Yeah, I stole guns from the
Wayne Township's police Department and if
I shoot you with them, it will trace back
to the police and that's okay because of the
Second Amendment."
And I started to get into it, but I was like
I don't think this guy, I don't think I really
want to debate Constitutional interpretation
with this guy.
So he started
yelling at me, and at one point, he brought
up the Jerry Springer show,and I was like,
just out of, for no reason, I was
like "I love that show."
And he was like "Really?
I do, too."
And I was like, "I love it when they get in
fights, and Steve
has to break them up."
And he was like, "yeah, Steve, man."
And then he goes, "I love when they have the
KKK on.
I love the
KKK." and I was just like, "Me too.
Yeah.
Me too, I love the KKK.
I love it."
And he calmed down a lot and then we were
just like
joking about the Jerry Springer show, and
I was just faking that I loved the KKK.
I DON'T love the KKK, just to be clear.
And then he started laughing, and the whole
time there'd been this other guy in the car
with him, who was a smaller guy
who'd pulled his hat down so we couldn't really
see him.
And then once the guy started laughing, it
felt like the tension
broke and I was going to get out of there,
and the skinny guy leaned over to the big
guy and whispered something, and the
big guy laughed, and I was like "What's up
man, what's so funny?"
And he goes, "I'm gonna have sex with you
now."
And I was
like, "Nah, I don't think.
I would really prefer that we didn't."
And he goes, "I'm gonna give you twenty dollars,
and
then I'm gonna have sex with you."
And I still don't know why he thought the
twenty dollars was necessary, like, it's not
[laughter]
like, there's no reality where I'd be like
"hmm, twenty, great."
And then he started to get out of his truck,
and I drove
into, I was like, well, I'm just going to
drive into the swamp.
And I drove into the swamp, and luckily managed
to make it
back out onto the road.
I didn't know how deep the swamp was and if
my car would make it through.
And then I realized, too, I
was like, those cars, I think, are probably
the cars of all the people this guy has killed,
and he's so big he just picks
them up and does that [laughter] and we drove
away and got out of there.
And as soon as we got back to the office,
my boss
was like, "Write that down" and we published
it and it was one of our most popular stories.[laughter]
And we started getting letters about this
dude, and we got letters, we got a letter
from a cop who said "I once had to
arrest him, and I put handcuffs on him, and
he was so physically strong that he just went
like this and broke the
handcuffs."
And then we got a letter from someone who
lived there, and she's like "it was a strange
little area, but I
liked living by the river, and it was peaceful,
and then I had to move because that guy killed
my dog with his hands."
And I was like, this is nuts.
We had gotten away, and he had chased us a
little bit, but just to sort of the border
of his
area.
Then we got one letter from a kid, who was
like, "We went back there and that guy chased
us, as well, and he didn't
stop.
He chased us for an hour, and I eventually
had to go the wrong way on Route 80 to get
away from him."
And if you know
Route 80, that's the road that starts at the
George Washington Bridge, and ends in California,
it's like America's mega-highway and he had
to drive the wrong way down it to get away
from the guy.
But then, the letters died down, and after
another year or so, we got one last letter
about the guy, where he was like "I'm a cop,
and I've dealt with that dude, too.
He's strangely enough, a good guy in his own
way.
He was a troubled individual.
The other guy you dealt with was his
brother, they had rough lives, and they were
definitely problematic people, but they had
good hearts.
And I wanted to let you to know
he died of a heart attack, the guy who tried
to assault you, and I figured you'd want to
know just for the story to come
full circle, but also, he was a huge fan of
Weird New Jersey, and he loved reading about
himself, and he'd been a subscriber
for years before he ever showed up in it."
And I was like "Oh my God, I've been writing
about this man, and he'd been
reading the whole thing."
And apparently just laughing about it.
So, that's my story about a shack, but it
didn't make the
cut for the book, so
>>male #2: Do you think that he knew you were
involved, that he was trying to, no,
>>Chris: No, I don't think so.
It's not like, when you work for a company
called Weird New Jersey, it's not like you
have a
company car [laughter] with like a logo on
the side.
It was just, at that point I was driving a
1986 Chevy Celebrity.
So he
just, we were just two people back there.
I don't think he was messing with us to try
to get into Weird New Jersey magazine,
and plus, that means every time he killed
a dog, he was like maybe they're an editor
at Weird New Jersey magazine.
[laughter]
So I don't think so.
So that's my shack story.
>>male #2: Excellent shack story.
>>Chris: Oh thank you so much.
I should have just told stories the whole
time, huh?
[applause]
Wow that got applause, oh no, all I've done
is wasted everyone's time!
Yeah, you agree, huh, Human Fish?
Um, but I don't know.
I wanted to put that other stuff out there.
Um, but yeah, that's a shack story.
>>male #2: You came here to convince people
to get the book, right?
To either purchase it, or
you know,
>>Chris: Yeah, I guess so, but as you can
tell, I'm not, I'm sort of allergic to money.
I'm sort of allergic to money and
success, so by all means, I hope people read
the book, and the stories in there, I hope
are funny.
But I also felt like, I
don't know, it's dumb, and it's a soapbox
moment, but to get a chance to talk at Google,
I'd rather talk about the stuff we
do that is Internet driven, as well as the
book, ya know?
Were there any other thoughts, or questions,
or questions for the
Human Fish?
>>Shannon: You guys keep motioning to your
friend over there
>>Bethany: Yeah.
>>Chris: Yeah, you're also the only crowd
that's reacted...
>>Shannon: You're like [whispering gibberish
sounds].
>>Unknown female speaker 3: [unintelligible
words]Ashanti?
>>Chris: What's that?
>>Shannon: Ashanti the singer?
>>Chris: Oh, okay, these are some people who
know
>>Shannon: you heard a shanty and you disappointed
them because your story was not about Ashanti.
It was about a shanty.
>>Chris: What they're referencing.
First of all, thanks for coming, because you're
people who clearly follow me, at least
one of you follows me on Twitter.
What they’re referencing is I've fallen
into a situation lately where someone made
a
Wikipedia page for me, which is nice.
That feels like an accomplishment of some
sort to have someone write a Wikipedia page
about you, but then other people have taken
to altering it.
And recently, no matter how many times the
editors of Wikipedia
go in and change it, someone insists on going
in and saying that I'm romantically linked
to the R and B singer, Ashanti.
Which
is not, which is not, although she's a lovely,
from what I can tell, she's a really lovely
woman and a really talented
person, and easy on the eyes, but those rumors
are untrue.
And not only do they keep saying I'm romantically
linked to
Ashanti, they keep going to Ashanti's Wikipedia
page and linking to her that she's linked
[laughter] to New York comedian,
Chris Gethard, which I have to imagine, if
you're Ashanti, feels so bad.
That has to feel so bad.
Apparently, she was
dating, I forget who she's really dating.
>>Female voices: Nelly.
>>Chris: Nelly.
So then I'm a really neurotic, paranoid guy,
and I have all these fears that at some point,
I'm going to be
walking down the street and Nelly's going
to be like "Yo," like, "Yo."
Like he's going to see me across the street
and he’s'
going to be like "That's Gethard!"
And I'm going to be like "How do you know
who I am, Nelly?"
And he's going to be like
"Cause there's rumors that you're sleeping
with my girl, Ashanti."
And I'm going to be like, “What’s the
likelihood that
that's true, Nelly?"
And he's going to be like, "Slim to none,
but it makes me nervous."
And I'll be like, "Nervous,
nervous, you got nothing to be nervous about
man.
You're Nelly, you've had three successful
songs in 2002, man.
Chill out.
All I did was star in a failed sitcom.
You're still way ahead of the curve on me,
Nelly."
And then Nelly's going
to punch me in the face and be like, "That's
in case you're lying."
And I'll be like, "This is just my luck."
>>Shannon: I liked that when you asked who
she was dating, all of them answered at the
same time.
Can we ask them another
pop culture question?
>>Chris: Yeah.
Are you guys Gethard fans or are you Ashanti
fans?
>>female #4: We were just talking about it
before we came.
>>Chris: But are you aware of the whole thing
through Ashanti's Wikipedia, or through mine?
>>female #4: Your Wikipedia.
>>Chris: My Wikipedia.
I'm hoping that you guys came to this event
being like, "We get to meet Ashanti's boyfriend!"
[Laughter]
That's my hope, is that that was your impulse
when you came here.
>>Shannon: So you Googled him before you came
here to figure out who you were going to see?
>>Chris: You're not familiar at all with stuff.
>>female #4: Um, no.
>>Chris: Fair.
Fair, thank you for cutting me down a peg,
Shannon.
>>Shannon: Yeah, yeah.
I just want to make sure.
>>Chris: I thought there was a small handful
of people in here who enjoyed what we do,
but we remain underground completely.
But I'm glad that's what you linked on to,
out of all the things to talk to on that,
to talk to me on that Wikipedia page.
I'm glad it's a fictional relationship with
someone way out of my league.
Thank you for that, thank you
for that.
[chuckles] Um, I don't know.
What else should we do?
>>Shannon: There's a question.
>>Chris: Okay, yeah.
>>male #3: In reference to your Wikipedia
entry, Human fish versus Wikipedia editors.
>>Chris: Human Fish versus Wikipedia editors.
>>Human Fish: Human fish.
[Shannon laughs loudly]
>>Chris: Human Fish.
He thinks that he can take down all the Wikipedia
editors.
[several voices speaking at once, unintelligible]
>>male #3: I think you have the culprit.
>>Chris: Okay, okay.
You think he's the one changing it to say
Ashanti.
I don't know if he knows
how keyboards or computers work.
I don't know what he thinks he's inside right
now.
But I don't know if he knows about
computers enough.
No.
>>Shannon: I'd be surprised if he knew who
Ashanti was over a pet rock.
>>Chris: Yeah.
>>Shannon: He didn't know what a pet rock
was.
>>Human Fish: Pet rock!
>>Chris: Human Fish, Google versus pet rock.
>>Human Fish: Google.
>>Chris: Wow, the only thing that has beat
pet rock so far is the concept of Google.
>>Human Fish: Google.
>>Shannon: I think that was fear
>>Human Fish: Google!
>>Shannon: I think that was a fear based answer.
>>Chris: You're so scared you're going to
have to talk to some of these people on the
way out.
>>Bethany: There's a question over there.
>>Chris: Yeah, just yell it out.
>>male #4: Human Fish, Ashanti versus a shanty.
>>Chris: Oh, tying it all together!
>>Bethany: That's what I was wondering.
[laughter]
>>Chris: Ashanti versus a shanty.
>>Human Fish: A shanty.
>>Chris: A shanty?!?!
Ashanti's so talented, You're not a fan.
Ashanti versus Rihanna?
>>Human Fish: Rihanna.
>>Chris: Wow, okay.
So you know what you're talking about, and
that seems like your real opinion, actually.
>>Human Fish: Rihanna.
[laughter]
>>Shannon: Sharks.
Sharks versus Chris Brown?
>>Chris: Okay.
>>Human Fish: Sharks.
>>Shannon: Good answer.
>>Chris: Good answer.
Is there anything else we'd like to talk about
today?
I don't know how much time, should I
tell another story, that went well.
[laughter]
>>Bethany: Yeah, tell a story.
>>Chris: Which, what one should I tell?
Another one, one that's in the book to entice
people to buy it, or one that's not
in the book?
>>Bethany: Do you guys have a preference?
>>Chris: The way that this book came about
is I just kept telling stories on stage until
I had about forty stories, and then
I had editors yell at me for five years about
how the whole thing read like a guy talking
on stage.
>>Shannon: Have them throw a suggestion out,
that'll--.
Do it the old school way.
>>Chris: Is there any sort of topic of interest?
>>female #5: Sharks.
>>Chris: Sharks?
[Shannon laughs] Do I have a story that involves
sharks?
>>male #5: Rap music.
>>Chris: Rap music?
Well, the Diddy story I already told.
>>male #5: Well, he's an entrepreneur.
>>Chris: He is an entrepreneur.
I'm trying to think of some of the other...
Oh!
You want to hear something crazy about Diddy?
If, now we're literally just talking about
someone more successful and
interesting.
Before he came and did our show, his assistant
kept calling me, and she got a kick out of
the whole thing, and
I was like, "It must be pretty crazy to be
Diddy's assistant sometimes, huh?"
And she's like, "Yeah, the weirdest was we
stayed up for five entire days, and eventually
I had a physical break down and started crying.
And he was like, 'Oh my God,
what's the matter?'
And I was like, 'Diddy, I need to go to sleep.'
And he went, 'Oh, I don't have to, so sometimes
I forget
other people need to sleep.'
" Diddy, apparently, can just stay awake endlessly
and only sleeps when he chooses to.
And then,
I'm honestly convinced that he is a magical
being, akin to like a unicorn, I'm honestly
convinced.
Because then, his
assistant called me right before the show
like the day before and was like, "Does your
theater have any computers or
TV's?"
And I was like, "Yeah, we have a computer
in our tech booth, and TV monitors out on
stage.
Why?"
And she was like, "Ah, it might be a problem."
And I was like "Why?", and she goes "Well,
there's this thing that
happens with Diddy where when he looks at
a computer or television monitor, he breaks
the device."
And I was like,"This is
weird."
And she was like, "Yeah, when he does his
reality shows, he can't even be in the room
when they're editing it
because he breaks all their computers, and
they do all this work and then he breaks the
computers when he looks at them."
And I was kinda like,we're already doing this
event, and everybody's, there's already so
much buzz about it, why is she
trying to like convince me,like you don't
have to convince me Diddy's cool.
I get he's cool.
Why are you throwing these BS
stories at me?
And then, on the night of the show, we were
backstage, and they came and got us, and they
were like,"Okay, alright,
Gethard, Diddy, time to do the show."
And we had made this video package of like
the videos where I had asked him to do the
show, on Fallon we had talked about it a little
bit, and we made this video package, and it
was playing.
We had tested the
video and it worked, and then we got to the
tech booth, and it was airing on a little
monitor there, and he was like "Oh,
what's this?
Oh, this is funny.
That's funny."
And he walked away, and the sound was like
thirty seconds off after he
looked at the screen.
Diddy, he did it, he broke it with his mind.
How could I ever doubt Diddy?
So now, honest to God,
if anybody ever comes up to me and says, "Oh,
you met Diddy once, I saw him walking in the
sky."
I'd be like, "Yeah, sure."
I will never ever doubt anything that Sean
Combs says he can do, ever again, like ,yeah,
if he told me, like.
If I ran into
Diddy again and he was like, "Hey dude, I
used my ability to travel into the future,
and everything's going to be okay."
I'd
genuinely feel better, because I think he
can probably do that.
So, there's a story about rap music.
I'm still trying to think about one about
sharks.
I don't think I have a shark story.
I have a goat story, that's the
closest one.
Why don't I, should I tell the Princeton story,
that's the best one.
>>Shannon: Yeah.
>>Chris: Can I tell you guys one more
>>Shannon: Mike Bramski
>>off screen voices: White magic's pretty
amazing too.
White magic, white magic
>>Chris: Oh, you like White Magic?
White Magic is weirdly more embarrassing.
I like the Princeton one because
>>female #5: Three minutes.
>>Chris: Three minutes.
[claps hands]
>>female #5: You've got three minutes for
White Magic.
>>Chris: Got White Magic.
So I grew up, I was huge into pro wrestling.
>>Shannon: That sounded very racist by the
way, for White Magic.
>>Chris: Three minutes for White Magic, it
did sound racist.
It wasn't racist.
You're not racist at all.
So, I grew up, I was huge into pro wrestling.
It was like an obsession of me and my brother,
and we had this friend named
Eddie who grew up across town, and he loved
wrestling, too.
And when I was a freshman in college, I hadn't
heard from Eddie
in a while, and then he called me up one day.
And he was like, "Hey, man."
Long story short, he basically goes, “This
is going
to sound weird but I took pro wrestling classes,
and I'm not good at it, but I met a lot of
contacts.
One of those contacts
is an agoraphobic man named Carmine."
And I was like, "He's scared of the world?"
and he was like, "He never ever, ever
leaves his house, but he owns a wrestling
league called the Stars and Stripes Championship
Wrestling League.
We're having an
event at Seton Hall University and I was wondering
if you would want to come be a manager and
manage a wrestler?"
And I was like, "This is amazing.
Yeah, of course, of course."
I get to be a wrestler, in my head, I was
like I finally get
to be a pro wrestler, that's always been my
dream.
So he told me to come up with a character,
and the character I came up
with was called "White Magic", and in my mind,
I'm like, I'll be a pimp.
I'll look like this and then I'll walk around
being
like "oh, man" and being like, "I got hoes
in all the zip codes" and I'll yell that at
people and they'll hate me.
The next
night, I had a conference call with the agoraphobic,
and he sounded very agoraphobic, and he was
like, "Chris, I’ve heard a
lot about you, Eddie has described to me what
you look like, what's your character?" and
I said, "Character's White Magic,
and I'll wear a smoking jacket, I'll wear
a top hat, I'll have a cane, and I'll got
up to people and say, 'like I'm going to
take your girlfriend out back,' and all this
stuff.
And he's like, "Oh that's great, that's great."
So we went to the event,
and oddly enough, there was like a few wrestlers
I had seen growing up in this dressing room.
The Iron Sheik, who wears the
curlicue boots, and he showed up in those,
I don't know how he drives with those.
King Kong Bundy was there, if you've ever
seen King Kong Bundy, he's like this five
hundred pound scary guy.
He had like a big feud with Hulk Hogan back
in the day.
I was like, man, King Kong Bundy.
So, we go out to have our match, Oh!
Even before that, very important, the guy
I was
managing was brand new, the guy he was up
against was named Flash Wheeler.
Flash Wheeler, they told me that I would have
to
hit Flash Wheeler with my cane to end the
match, and I was not comfortable with that,
and Flash Wheeler was not comfortable
with that.
And he came up to me and he said, “I don't
know what you're doing here, you're not trained
in this, if you hit me
with that thing wrong, and uh, hurt me, I'm
gonna beat you up.
Like, I'm just going to beat you up."
And he was this huge
pro wrestler.
And I was like, "Okay.
That's fair."
And they were like, your match goes out to
start, and I went out,
started telling all my schtick to people,
telling them.
At one point, this guy started yelling at
me, and I was like, "Don't
make me slap those last two hairs off your
bald head."
And all the crowd booed.
There's another guy started to talk to me,
and I was like, "Don't make me hit you in
front of your daughters."
The whole crowd was like booing and I was
doing a good
job.
So the match happened, and it was really really
bad, and the kid who I was managing was nervous.
And Flash was hitting
him really hard, every time the kid would
mess up a move, Flash would hit him really
hard, and you could see like red
hand prints all over him, and it was scary.
And all I could think about was, if I do this
thing with the cane wrong,
he's gonna beat me up.
So Flash gave me the signal, and he ran across
the ring, and I jumped up on the edge of the
ring
with my cane, and I froze completely.
So he looked at me, and he just kept running,
so now he had to pretend that one throw from
Vicious Vin meant that he had to run three,
that Vicious Vin is so strong that I just
have to keep running.
And he ran back
to me, and I raised, I was like you have to
do it, you have to do it.
And I hit him largely like this[loud laughter]
No joke, like orchestra conductors hit the
stand harder.
I was like, "uh."
And he looked at me, and he was like,
“Ahhhhhh..." and he sold it and then Vicious
Vin pinned him.
And in my head, for a brief moment,maybe he'll
just, maybe this
crowd will just think like I'm amazingly strong.
They didn't.
They started booing me, and yelling at me,
but it wasn't like
booing like a wrestling, like you want from
a wrestling crowd anymore, now it was like,
"You are horrible at what you do."
And they were booing me, and chaos erupted
around me, and I was like filled with fear.
And I went to walk back towards the
dressing room, these thirteen year old kids,
they must have been like twelve or thirteen,
jumped out of the crowd, and over
the barrier in front of me, and one of them
pushed me, and I was like, "Oh my God, what's
going on?"
And one of them reached up and grabbed my
top hat off my head, and where before I was
like, "in front of your kids, don't
make me slap you, old man."
This guy, this kid, not guy, kid grabbed my
top hat, and the best I could come up with
was,
“Hey, I need that."
And the whole crowd just started booing me
and throwing trash at me and stuff.
And it was like the most
shame I have ever felt in my life,
[laughter]
which is saying so much, so much.
And a wrestler, I had forgotten that because
we cheated, these other wrestlers were
supposed to come out and fight and defend
Flash Wheeler's honor, and one of them grabbed
me and he threw me back towards the dressing
room, really hard, kind of clearly as a "you
messed up the whole match"thing, and the dressing
room wasn't an actual room,
they had built these, set up this big partitions
that were almost floor to ceiling, and then
connected them with curtains.
And I hit it, chest first, and it went like
this, and then back towards me, and then it
collapsed inward, and it brought
down all the curtains, and all the partitions,
and there were all these like naked wrestlers
who were like "Uh, what?"
like
this whole crowd looking at them.
It came about this far, no kidding, this wall
I knocked over came about this far from
crushing King Kong Bundy, who is like three
quarters naked at the time.
And, a wrestler named Skull Von Crush, grabbed
me,
as they, his whole gimmick was that he was
like a Nazi, and he kind of seemed like he
was into it, he kind of seemed like it
was born out of his real life.
He grabbed me and threw me in a corner and
said, "You almost killed Bundy, like we're
gonna
mess you up."
And I was like, "I didn't, Dude.
It was an accident.
I can't kill Bundy.
Bundy's Bundy!"
And he's yelling at
me, and Bundy went out to wrestle his match
at that point, and then, thankfully, at one
point, King Kong Bundy, the fire alarm
just went off, and we were all like what happened?
How can this be more of a fiasco,and someone
said, "Bundy got body
slammed, and he's so big he shook the foundation
of the building,and the fire alarms got set
off.
And all the wrestlers went
that way to look, and I grabbed all my stuff,
and ran out the back door.
I was like "I'm out of here!
This is horrible!"
And I ran out, and I ran to my car,and as
I ran to my car, I saw another emergency exit
get kicked open, and my brother came
running out, he instinctively knew that I
would be fleeing in a panic.
And he came out, and he had my top hat, and
we got to
the car, and he was like,"That was a complete
disaster!"
And I said, "I know, how did you get my top
hat back?"
And he said,"They were little kids, I took
it, I went up and I took it from them, they
were little kids."
So that's the abridged, the
version of the White Magic story in the book
is much longer, but that's the abridged version.
It's mostly how I signed up to
live a dream, the dream quickly turned into
a nightmarish reality, and then I got chumped
by, literally, a bunch of
prepubescent children.
[electric crackle]
Ah, you jerk!
You jerk, that hurt so bad.
[applause] [laughter]
Thank you, guys very much, I hope the rambling
was okay, and I hope that the boring parts
weren't so boring.
And I'm glad
that we got to tell a few stories, and I'm
glad that we got to talk about some of the
Internet driven stuff that we do.
So thanks for putting up with us, it really
means a lot.
>>Shannon: Thank you.
>>Human Fish: Pet rock!
[applause]